christian well this one is very far from
over but one game that was over was the
one between katarina nemtsova
and
um zatonski one of the leaders in this
event and katarina won a brilliant game
and she is with maurice thanks katarina
i know
we met at the airport coming in and you
were telling me you had a lot of things
on your plate doing a phd
uh
all of the all of the busy things that
have kept you over the last year
and then round one you get anna have you
ever defeated her
um it's a good question i don't think so
i think we always made the draw
now what was different this game it
seemed like it was close until suddenly
she completely collapsed
i think it was a really interesting
opening like i wanted to run with my
pawns and then i wasn't sure how much i
want to run because i was like i should
castle but then i wanted to think about
you know g4 like there are so many good
options and i was breaking in the center
like e4
king in the middle uh so maybe it was
equal by the computer but i wasn't sure
if i'm better i thought i'm better at
some moment than i thought it maybe i'm
not after she played like rook c7 so i
thought it was like very interesting
game and then i totally missed knight d7
and i was like oh no i blundered a pawn
on f4 and then i was like oh maybe there
are some complications with the queen
being pinned let's take a look at the
moment you're talking about right here
on the screen
let's get to the position
further down
and it looks like you do have great play
and you said this was the moment oh it's
it's equal okay i guess everything is
equal with the computer but yeah i was
thinking about rook e3 going back but
then
i guess it's a little weaker because
then rook takes on f4
queen g3
the other rook to f7 and now i cannot
capture the pawn on e6 because
there is rookie one i think actually i'm
not sure now but maybe knight takes f4
but i just became worried that the rook
on e3 is like protecting the queen but
then can never capture anything so the
rook on g5 is still kind of tricky
because it's thinking about maybe you
know sacking on g6 on a good day yeah
so that's actually interesting we didn't
get a chance to follow your your
position very tightly but here you felt
you had actually
not seen the move knight d7 got to go
upon down
but still with some compensation and
then suddenly a lot of compensation once
united got to e5 and she blundered rook
f6 yes i was thinking that she should
have played instead of knight f8
um i think something like queen before i
was looking at
it's like a sharp moment to be leaving
that king alone
but certainly still looks fine
i guess everything's the rookie six is
also on the board but you know we have
like two minutes on clock i was thinking
so much in the opening uh so it was a
very complicated position and then rook
f5 happened and i was like oh shoot i
didn't see that move and i was like i
think that's a blunder
[Laughter]
well you did manage to hit her with that
pin and suddenly you were able to
capture and
capture again and end the game quickly
good start to the tournament beating one
of the favorites aspirations for winning
the tournament itself too early or did
you come in with ambitions into the
event my ambition was just to play chess
and hopefully good chess and that's
really as far as i'm going with my
ambitions all right well we'll let you
get a chance to rest congratulations on
your win thank you
welcome